After weeks of relentless fighting,
Ukraine says Russian troops are advancing
on the city of Bakhmut.
Now, according to Ukrainian
military officials,
Russian forces
are assaulting
the city itself, suggesting that
it is no longer
simply operating on the outskirts.
But Ukraine does not plan to withdraw yet
its defense forces are still holding on
to their positions
and are repelling Russian attacks.
Now, the boss of the mystery Wagner
Group says this video you're
looking at here
shows is fighters practically
in the center of the city.
However, CNN has geolocated this video
to be the east of Bakhmut,
around two kilometers or
so from the city center.
Meanwhile, Ukraine fears
that if Paramount falls
the town of Charles River,
as you can see,
there will be the next on Russia's list.
Alex Marquardt is there
This is the road
on the way to back mud
cars, military vehicles
bombing up and down this road, going to
and from the front
You see this armored vehicle right here
as a sign for victory.
There are still some people here,
not too many,
but some of these hardy residents
have stayed behind.
This is the shop of Sea views.
Who is here?
Grilling meats held shashlik.
He actually fled from Bark Mound
two months ago
and has opened up the shop selling basics
like bananas, beetroot and and candles.
There's another man
who here who we just met
whose daughter is still in mud.
One of the thousands of people there
who have been asked to evacuate
but are still in the city.
Amid this incredible fighting,
you can see that
they put up wood there, too,
to protect those windows.
So much destruction in this town.
We were just farther in
the center of town, is called it,
because if you are,
this is one town
over from back
with a large group of people
at a bus stop
waiting for a water delivery
that never came.
Every few moments
you can hear explosions.
The sound of
what we believe
to be outgoing artillery fire.
Ukrainians firing at Russian positions.
We spoke with an older
woman named Valentina
who said that
there is so much flying over their heads
that she is scared all the time.
That they are so close
to the Russian positions.
That's more outgoing artillery fire.
They are so close
to the Russian positions
that they can walk there.
We also spoke
with some Ukrainian soldiers
like these ones
who man one of those artillery positions.
They told us that there has been no order
to pull back from back mount,
that there are fighting
because if they give up back mud,
then this town transfer,
this would be next.
And that is what everyone is thinking
now, that if
Russia were to take back mud,
that they would have another foothold
in this region
from which
to try to push farther
into eastern Ukraine.
Alex Marquardt, CNN, in charge of air.
Well, for the first time
since Russia invaded Ukraine, U.S.
Secretary of State
Antony Blinken has met
with Russian Foreign Minister
Sergei Lavrov.
They spoke for about 10 minutes
on the sidelines
of the G20 foreign ministers meeting.
That's happening in New Delhi.
Discussing the war in Ukraine,
the new START
nuclear arms reduction treaty
and Pull Will
and of course, the US
citizen who's been in Russian
prison system for years.
Natasha Bertrand is following the story
and joins me now from Washington.
So Natasha, what more do we know
came out of that meeting
and indeed who initiated this meeting
to start off with?
Yeah.
So we're actually
told that
it was the Secretary of State,
Antony Blinken,
who did initiate that meeting
and you know,
it was described
more as a spur of the moment type thing
where Blinken did seek out Lavrov
on the sidelines of the G20
to have a conversation
with him about various subjects.
But there were no formal
negotiations, right?
Nothing very
formal in terms of a meeting
between the US and Russia.
But it was an opportunity
for Blinken to raise
a couple of very key issues.
Among them, of course,
the New START treaty,
trying to encourage the Russians
to get back into that nuclear arms treaty
that they withdrew from
just a couple of weeks
ago, saying that responsible
nations need,
of course, these nuclear guardrails.
And then, of course,
he brought up the case of Paul Whelan,
who is the American
who has been detained in Russia
for nearly five years.
Of course,
the US now
says that they have put forward
another substantive proposal
to Russia to get Paul Whelan back,
but that the Russians have not engaged.
And then finally, of course,
the biggest subject of all is that
is the war in Ukraine.
And he encouraged the Russians,
of course, to abide
or to to sit down
and talk with the Ukrainians
and come to a peace agreement,
noting that the Ukrainians,
President Olinsky,
had put forward a ten point peace
plan of his own
and for the Russians to start engaging
with that in good faith.
And that was really the overall
theme of the discussions,
Blinken said at
the G-20 was not only urging Russia
to pull out of Ukraine,
but also warning other allies of China's
potential plans to arm
Russia
with lethal equipment, saying that
that is just unacceptable to the US
and that many allies
are concerned about that.
So it was an opportunity
for Blinken rather informally
to meet face to face with Lavrov
for the first time since the war began.
And raised these top issues of concern
for the United States. These.
And sticking with Ukraine
were G20 leaders on the same page
in regard to the war in Ukraine, because
there was no communique
Not exactly.
So according to the Russian readout
of their meeting with the Chinese,
they say that
the Russians and the Chinese
were very much on the same page
with regard to the war in Ukraine.
Of course,
China did issue its own
kind of peace
proposal for that war
that the United States
and the West are extremely skeptical of.
And the US has said.
Anthony
Blinken said during a press conference
earlier today
that in fact the US had warned
many of the allies at that G-20 summit
about China's
contemplation of sending Russia
that lethal equipment
and the fact that many of those allies
were deeply concerned by that.
And so
I think
what you saw here was kind of a divide,
of course,
between the kind of us led
Western alliance
at the G20,
the kind of China Russia alliance there,
and then India, which was of course
the host of the summit,
kind of in the middle.
Of course, we have seen the U.S.
express concerns
about India
not condemning
Russia's war in Ukraine,
and of course, India buying up
a lot of that oil
that is keeping Russian profits afloat
and allowing them to continue the war.
So it was a really interesting
dynamic here.
But of course, we're seeing the push
and pull on both sides from the US
and from Russia, China, India,
to basically come
to some kind of solution here
with regard to
the war
does not look like
that's going to happen
any time soon, however.
Yeah.
Natasha Bertrand for us in Washington,
thanks very much, Natasha.
So let's discuss
all of this with retired
Air Force Colonel Cedric Leighton
and CNN political
and national security
analyst David Sanger.
David, I want to start with you.
So a State Department official told us
not to expect Russia
to change course after this meeting.
That's not particularly surprising.
But the source also said
that Blinken was the one
who approached Lavrov
on the sidelines of the G-20 here.
Why does the US want to have
this kind of engagement
with Russia at this moment?
Well, Abby,
there's been
very little conversation at high levels
between Russia and the United States
in the year
plus a few days
since the invasion happened.
It was only one phone
call on the question of prisoner releases
between Secretary Blinken and Lavrov.
The last time they had met in person,
Blinken confronted
Lavrov with the evidence
that an invasion was about to happen.
And Lavrov continued to denial that
that Russia was going to invade.
And in fact,
we believe that Lavrov probably
wasn't told about the invasion
until just hours before it happened.
So there's a
really interesting question here
about whether he's the right person
to be talking to.
But since you
can't have President Biden
talking to Putin, these days,
this is the only real channel left.
I think the most important part of that,
obviously trying to get Paul Way
Whalen out,
but also communicating directly
with the Russians about the long term
danger of their suspension of involvement
in the New START treaty,
because that treaty expires
in three years.
And there's almost no chance
that there's going to be a negotiation
to extend it, at which point
there will be no limits on either
country's nuclear forces.
Yeah,
I mean, Colonel Leighton, on that point,
what is the strategic value for Russia
in suspending their participation
in this treaty?
Are they now
free to engage
in expanding their arsenal?
And is there any putting the genie
back in the bottle if that happens?
Yeah, that's a big problem, Abby.
And I'm actually very concerned
that the genie might not be able
to be
put back in the bottle at this point.
As to what the Russians want to do is
they could
potentially be able to use
this lack of limits.
They have a little less
than 6000 warheads
right now in their nuclear arsenal.
They could potentially expand that number
and they could also develop
newer weapons.
We talked to before
about their hypersonic
weapons capability.
We also know that they may be refining
some of their nuclear capabilities.
So that's the kind of thing
that we're looking at.
It would not surprise me
if they would want to try to modernize
their nuclear forces during this period.
And so that is something
that we would definitely have to
watch out for.